psychedelic drugs are being used for
medicinal purposes
some of these authors have appeared on
book tv you can watch them on our
website booktv.org
[Applause]
i have to have this is what it's all
about
welcome john let me add my
welcome to the commonwealth thank you
for having me yeah
john was actually asking me
a little bit about the commonwealth club
and i was
i was happy to brag
about the fact that it's a
place where people of all opinions and
points of view and political persuasions
come and we can hear what they have to
say and it's a it's a rare um
forum in today's world where
you don't just hear one side of the
story right so i think we should all
give ourselves a a hand for the fact
that there is in exists in the world a
place like this organization
well we're here tonight to principally
talk about
your
brand new book
the the title is not one that would make
you buy it at an airport store but um
yeah but maybe the
the secondary title secrets and lies in
a silicon valley startup that would that
would catch my attention but it's it's a
fascinating story about
a circumstance that i suspect many of
you familiar with because it happened
right in our own backyard in fact i
shouldn't use the past tense because it
technically continues to happen
and so what i'm going to do is not
assume everybody has such a tactile
familiarity that we can just get into
the subtleties of the stories let's
let's start with the basic framework
kind of the executive summary of what
brought you facebook
well i guess the first i'll explain the
the
story of fairness um
uh a young woman named elizabeth holmes
uh
dropped out of stanford university uh
when she was 19 years old in the middle
of her sophomore year
because she had um
a vision uh for uh
a technology that she wanted to create
she wanted to be a successful
entrepreneur
follow she very much wanted to follow in
the footsteps of steve jobs whom she
admired and uh the the original vision
was for a
wristband
um that would have these micro needles
that would draw uh minutes amounts of
blood
uh from your wrist and um diagnose you
with whatever ailed you and and
simultaneously inject you with the
appropriate drug and cure you
um yeah
that's ambitious she called it the
therapatch
and in her early uh uh pitches to
investors there was a little diagram
that showed you know the therapatch and
actually the theropatch was more uh
science fiction than it was reality and
she and her co-founder um
realized that after a few months and
pivoted to uh something that was more
inspired
by uh the portable glucose monitors that
diabetes patients used to monitor their
blood sugar
except elizabeth wanted uh her portable
device to be able to do every blood test
uh from just a pinprick of blood how
many is that approximately i mean
if you're talking the full range of
laboratory tests it's anywhere from
several hundred to several thousand wow
um and uh
no one had been able to do that uh
before so um you know it was an ambi it
was still an it wasn't the wristband but
it was still an ambitious
endeavor and um she uh
proceeded to to build up this company
over the the next decade
um went through several iterations of
the technology
and uh by
late 2013 fall of 2013
uh via partnership with walgreens uh
commercialized her finger stick tests
in walgreens stores in
two
blood draw centers in in the palo alto
area and another 40 or 45 in arizona
and um
became a
star and a celebrity here and and even
beyond silicon valley
she got a lot of press coverage she
graced the cover of fortune magazine in
june 2014 uh clad in a steve job-esque
uh black turtleneck
um with a very catchy headline uh the
ceo is out for blood
and um
you know made became a fixture on the
the tech conference uh the healthcare
conference circuit uh was invited to the
white house several times
um
won various awards uh was uh invited to
join the
the uh board of fellows at harvard
medical school which is a very
prestigious body
um and was fed as uh
the the world's youngest self-made
female billionaire because by early 2014
their nose had achieved a valuation of
more than nine billion dollars
and she had kept more than half of the
equity and so she was worth almost five
billion dollars at that point
um
and uh so in a nutshell that's that's
the story of theranos and um
we're gonna loop back but one thing
that's interesting is well two things
one that i thought of when you were
saying it wasn't just that these blood
tests became available they became
available retail so right right so you
don't need a doctor to go through
exactly and the first
part of theranos's history the business
model had been different
she
pitched pharmaceutical companies and the
idea was that pharmaceutical companies
would use these
user-friendly fast painless
finger stick tests
in clinical trials to test new drugs and
so the patients enrolled in clinical
trials would have
the theranos blood testing device in
their home and they would prick their
finger several times a day
and the the results would be beamed to
the the trial sponsor and and
pharmaceutical companies
uh would be able to save billions of
dollars on clinical trials or so
elizabeth claimed
um and it was only later in starting in
2010 that she pivoted to a direct
consumer model
and um and the the uh there were two
retail partners that she wooed
and one in particular uh walgreens uh is
the uh drugstore chain through which she
was able to commercialize the uh
technology and the other point that just
to get our facts based here is her board
of directors
who who was the board of directors
so in uh 2011 she met
george schultz through someone at the
stanford medical school
and you all know who probably who george
schultz is a famous former secretary of
state
crafted the reagan administration's
foreign policy uh is credited by many
with winning the cold war
um
uh in his 90s now but remains a revered
figure in republican circles and he
lives right off the stanford campus
has always been very passionate about
science and when he met elizabeth holmes
he was really impressed with what she
told him about her technology
um and uh
he soon thereafter joined her board
and then introduced her to his buddies
at the hoover institution the the think
tank on the stanford campus and that's
how she got to meet henry kissinger and
bill perry uh former secretary of
defense under
bill clinton um
uh
sam nunn uh bill frist uh
and uh some former military commanders
like admiral ruff head
and and
they all eventually joined the board and
so by uh the time 2013 2014 came around
she had this unbelievable board of
of um
you know x statement and retired
military commanders who had uh
incredible resumes and general mattis
general mattis as well our current uh
secretary of defense yep
but there's something interesting there
in that they are all really
smart successful people
but
what do they know about
biochemistry and that's right
not much not much
you know if you thought about i think a
lot of people were impressed with this
board and few people stopped to think
but what does george show us and what do
henry kissinger and
sam nunn and jim mattis uh know about
medicine and uh lab testing in
particular
and i think there were about 12 uh men
on that theronus board and only two of
them had any connection to medicine
whatsoever
and uh and none of them had any
expertise whatsoever and and diagnostics
um and so uh
if you thought about that for a second
that was a major red flag
yeah and it was either a tell or it was
a great reason to invest
right right yeah and this there's this
uh uh hedge fund based in in san
francisco
uh called part partner fund management
that um
met with elizabeth and and sonny bahwani
her number two executive who also
happened to secretly be her boyfriend
in uh late 2013 and 2014 and and tried
to do due diligence and and were
essentially bald-faced lied to about
many things including revenue and profit
projections and binders of data that
weren't real and so on and so forth but
one of the things that really sold them
on theranos was the board of directors
uh they
were really um
impressed by the uh you know the
credentials of these people and
um it didn't occur to them that uh a
startup with a board that was that
impressive
could be up to no good uh not to mention
that the
the lawyer keeping um you know watch on
the shop was david boyes yeah all right
bush v gore right right yeah
um so
let's loop back because
a lot of your book is around the culture
of the company from where
how it started originally and
how it evolved particularly when the
walgreens and safeway situation so give
us some insight into some of the
anecdotal examples for example of the
way the company worked
so from from uh
early on um the the culture of theranos
was one of secrecy and and paranoia
um and elizabeth like to
compartmentalize uh information and to
um you know keep the the overall picture
of the device's development to herself
and uh the communications between say
the the engineers
and the chemists wasn't necessarily
encouraged
she also
fired a lot of people during the early
years there was constant turnover
i would say this culture
really
went into overdrive when her boyfriend
sonny balwani
who was 19 years older
whom she had met when she was just a
teenager before even starting her
undergraduate studies at stanford and he
was a software he was a he came from a
software background and and he had
gotten wealthy at the very top of the
internet bubble um when he had joined a
tiny startup
a few months before the tech bubble
popped
and uh
and a couple months before it got
acquired for some 250 million dollars
and he had walked away with more than 40
million dollars
and so when elizabeth first met him um
coming out of high school you know she
saw him as this
successful older successful silicon
valley
um entrepreneur and she wanted to become
uh successful and and wealthy
and and so he became sort of her um
uh
advisor her
the guy who would who would teach her
about business and in silicon valley
and uh eventually they became a couple
and um
he divorced uh the the artist he had
been married to and moved to palo alto
bought a condo she moved in with him
in 2005 and for the first um
five six years of the company
he uh was her advisor behind the scenes
but he didn't actually work at the
company
and he that changed in late 2009 at that
point theranose had burned through 47
million dollars
that it had raised in three rounds
and was on the verge of bankruptcy and
he stepped in and agreed to guarantee a
uh
bank credit line that the company took
out to stay afloat
and at that point uh he joined the
company as the number two executive the
the president and chief operating
officer and then that early culture of
paranoia and secrecy
really went to overdrive with him um
he uh
had a very short temper
and um you know the the firings if
anything increased uh to the point that
a new expression was coined
inside theranos which was uh to
disappear someone um
when when colleagues
uh you know no longer showed up at the
office um
you know their their uh
former colleagues would say well sonny
uh disappeared to him or her yeah um and
uh you know as i uh recount in the book
uh
it was just a constant stream of firings
there were also people
um quite a few employees who left
of their own
volition you know
because they had developed qualms and
and
they didn't want to be a party to what
was going on anymore but it was really
an unhealthy uh culture and
um i was at kepler's books last night
doing a
a talk in a book signing in menlo park
and there were quite a few ex theranos
employees who came yeah and uh
yeah and and then a lot of them got in
the line um the book signing line and uh
some of them uh you know
didn't know one another because they had
worked at the company during different
eras
and uh and they called themselves uh
there are no survivors
um
and uh and i i heard them you know use
this term in the line
um so there was an aspect of working at
or you know largely working at their
house was not a pleasant experience
because of this culture the reason i
think this is important um is not
because of the anecdotal nature of it
but because you would expect exactly the
opposite in these unicorn
type startup companies particularly ones
who are intending to be disruptive and
in industry you would think it would be
kind of open space everybody talks to
each other the ceo
sits with everybody else and talks and
there's
chat and crosstalk and that because
that's how ideas percolate up right
right so but at a certain point
i mean theranose really is the story of
a a young startup founder who
uh had a habit of over promising to
raise money and
with the years the over-promising got
worse and worse and the gap between
where her technology was and and what
she promised became enormous
to the point that when they went live
with the the blood tests in walgreens
stores in the fall of 2013
that
the gap was so huge that that they had
to cheat and they had to hack
uh commercial machines to try to uphold
this myth that they had actually created
new technology
and um
part of the the siloing and and the
secrecy and the paranoia
became to
uh hide
these shenanigans yeah and and
um when i finally published my first
story in in october of 2015 a lot of uh
employees weren't even even aware
of what they had done in the lab and
weren't even even aware that only a few
of the blood tests were done with the
theranost device and that most of them
were done with these hacked commercial
machines because
you know they weren't authorized to go
into the lab you needed uh
to to
there was a finger print scanner to get
in the lab and if you weren't if your
finger hadn't been scanned and
pre-approved you couldn't get in there
and you didn't know what was going on
so um
the culture became about hiding not just
uh what they were doing from the outside
but also hiding from many employees on
the inside what was going on so that's
in a sense i mean the board was to tell
that in a sense is another tell because
if you were really
committed to what you're talking about
and felt you could do it i think you'd
operate 180 degrees different let's go
back to the first maybe what in my mind
at least was the first encounter with
under performance that was the novartis
uh
right test
so the uh prologue is about um of the
book is
the chief financial officer at the time
uh
sees uh elizabeth holmes and several of
her colleagues this takes place in
november 2006 come back from
a demonstration of the device in
switzerland at novartis one of the
biggest pharmaceutical companies in the
world
and um
you know she's
excited and happy to go lucky the way
she usually is but the
employees who went with her are not and
they look like something has gone wrong
and so he wanders downstairs and he
tries to figure out what what happened
and he approaches uh sonic roy
elizabeth's co-founder
and sonic wasn't exactly sure what had
happened in switzerland but after
talking to him for a while
uh he gleans from sonic that actually
these demos that they've been uh doing
for investors for investors who have
been coming by the office are not real
because the the blood test results at
the end of the demos are pre-recorded
and and not you know in real time
and uh the cfo at this point who's been
there eight months
uh
is stunned because he's the one who's
been bringing around all these investors
and making projections yeah and he's
he's under the impression the demos were
real and and and they're certainly under
the impression that they're they're real
and and he learns that they're not
and so um he decides to confront
elizabeth and goes to her office and and
meets with her
and uh
tells her that this is a line that they
can't cross you know that it's okay to
be aspirational
as a startup founder but you can't um
you can't essentially lie and mislead
investors that's securities fraud and uh
she uh
you know sort of switches flipped and
she goes from happy go lucky to
ice cold and she looks at him and she
says you know
you're not a team player
i think you should get out of here right
now and it's clear that she doesn't just
mean out of her office she's from the
company she means he's fired right and
and uh i used that scene as the prologue
because
i knew it was you know a good way to
hook readers and right
make them turn the page
but i also also thought that um
it was uh emblematic of the fact that um
at this company the unethical behavior
uh isn't something that suddenly
happened late in the game where suddenly
they they were painted into a corner and
crossed you know and cut corners it was
actually uh it started very early on
and you know that that scene takes place
um
a couple years after she's founded the
company she's 22 years old and and uh it
shows that you know that the unethical
behavior was part of the dna of the
company
and then the tennessee tests right
then uh
when they were still so there were three
iterations of the theranos technology
and the first was a microfluidic system
microfluidics refers to the field that
has repurposed the microfabrication
techniques that were pioneered by the
computer chip industry to move tiny
quantities of fluids and uh that that
field was um
you know just coming up when elizabeth
holmes launched her startup and
there's a lot of excitement about it and
uh they made a real effort to to build a
microfluidic blood testing system
um unfortunately uh
they uh it wasn't working and and uh
and she lost patients um and i she was
probably under pressure because she had
made all these promises to investors and
so she pivoted away from it but even as
she pivots away from it in late 2007
she's already started a pilot study with
pfizer
um
whereby the the theranos system has been
installed in
the homes of terminal cancer patients in
in tennessee
who are um uh in clinical trials getting
uh
drug anti-tumor drugs to drugs that will
arrest the the growth of their tumors
and hopefully buy them a few more months
of life and
um
you know uh back then there were some
employees that sort of
realized that
it wasn't right to use a blood testing
system that didn't work at all and to
and and granted one thing to bear in
mind is that back then the
the theronous blood tests weren't used
to inform the treatment of these cancer
patients it was a validation experiment
and they were to be compared with
the the blood the regular blood tests
that pfizer
was doing the regular way
but
employees were still appalled that
these terminal cancer patients in
tennessee were being put through these
needless you know finger stick uh
draws several times
a day for a technology that absolutely
didn't work
um and then in the middle of that uh
pilot study she pivoted away from the
the microfluidic platform and to what
was essentially a glue dispensing robot
a theranos engineer ordered a glue
dispensing robot from a
company called fiznar fisner new jersey
and um
it's made to dispense glue right and a
fixed uh a pipette at the end of the
robotic arm the robotic arm had uh three
degrees of motion
forward and back left and right and up
and down
and
and he reprogrammed the robotic robotic
arm to sort of mimic
what a lab scientist would do at the bet
at the bench when he was testing blood
and um
employees when that pivot to to this
machine happened um some employees you
know
felt let down because it was it was a
huge step down from uh
the microfluidics and and so they took
to derisively referring to referring to
this machine as the glue bot
and
but
elizabeth holmes was excited about it
she had a a well-known industrial
designer named ibaya
design a sleek black and white case for
it uh to hide its innards and it had a
digital user interface
and she christened it the edison after
thomas edison
and uh and this happened as they were
you know this pivot to what was
essentially a completely different
machine and a much more rudimentary one
happened in the middle of this
validation study using these these
cancer patients in tennessee as as
guinea pigs essentially
you remind me actually maybe something
we
maybe went over too fast is that
her whole model was based on using
capillary blood as opposed to
blood from your veins explain why that's
such a big difference
well
it's not just the the fact that you're
getting such a small sample of blood
it's also that capillary blood tends to
be polluted by um
tissue from from cells and um
it's not as if you're drawing blood from
the
the tip of your finger you're just not
getting as pure
a sample of blood as you are when you're
doing it uh with a needle from the arm
and uh one one problem in particular
with capillary blood is known as
lysis
and when you're
pricking the figure and that milking it
to get the blood out
often you're putting stress on the red
blood cells and they explode
and that creates more potassium that
releases potassium and that creates more
potassium than there otherwise would be
in the blood and so uh a problem that no
one has solved with uh
uh finger stick with capillary blood is
is the potassium assay
it's
you know there have been studies showing
that that
potassium tests are completely
unreliable
uh when they're done on capillary blood
and as i recount in the book
that's one of the big problems that
their nose encountered as well
how do you um
interpret this obsession
with steve
jobs so
um well first of all you have the
history of the of the holmes family uh
her ancestors were the fleischmann yeast
uh family
um
you know who were some of the richest
people in america at the turn of the
20th century and and her father had
raised her um
with um you know the knowledge of their
uh great success but also
uh with the knowledge that the later
generations of the family had squandered
the wealth his grandfather
had lived a very hedonistic lifestyle on
an island he had purchased in hawaii
and squandered most of the money and
then his son squandered the rest and so
there was um she was raised with you
know this
this uh notion that once upon a time the
holmes had been
wealthy people you know
uh
at the top of sort of the
uh yeah they were elite they were the
elites of america once upon a time and
and that wasn't the case anymore and so
i think
she had um
this desire to to um
recreate that and and um
and she was also um steve jobs you know
in silicon valley she was starry-eyed
about it and steve jobs was very much
her idol
um she uh revered apple
and and i think the enormous mistake
that she made is that um she modeled
herself after jobs and after
basically the computer industry after
you know the traditional
silicon valley tech industry um
and
instead she should have modeled herself
after perhaps the the biotech cluster in
south san francisco you know the the
genentechs of the world that have been
doing real medical science for decades
now but instead she chose as her model
the computer hardware and software
industry
and it wasn't the right model right
there's been this culture
for a long time now in silicon valley of
fake it till you make it you know and
and uh the term vaporware was coined in
the early 80s to describe uh computer
software or hardware that was announced
with great fanfare by company and then
never delivered or delivered years late
without the features that were promised
you know
people like jobs and larry ellison were
accused at various points of engaging in
this practice
and
i think if you looked at it from the
point of view of elizabeth holmes she
thought well that's okay because
eventually they did make it you know
these companies did become the real
thing uh with real products and they
were juggernauts and their founders
became billionaires and icons in america
and that was her plan uh to use that
same playbook but the problem is you you
can't really uh
use or you can't roll out vaporware in
medicine you know the medical arena is a
different arena
and the the end consumer um
is not you know
someone using a buggy smartphone app
it's a patient right who in this case is
relying on a blood test result to make a
crucial medical decision yeah and i
think she either lost sight of that or
conveniently ignored it
but
you know the the the traditional silicon
valley playbook
isn't applicable to to medicine and
unfortunately she tried to apply it to
medicine if my app crashes it's if i get
a false negative on that blood test
twitter was famously buggy you know in
its early years i mean it would
not work for hours at a time um
and uh you know
the consequence was frustration on the
part of its users but um it didn't put
anyone in danger
so speaking of putting people in danger
i want to go to the walgreens
safeway
part um
we kind of have a i think a
general assumption that large
institutions have checks and systems in
place so that they don't
get way out on a limb right
how did walgreens
get
where they did it's one of the craziest
parts of the story um
there's a chapter in the book uh
uh i think it's chapter seven of the
book uh where
i i recount
you know walgreens's attempt at due
diligence if you could call it that
uh when
elizabeth and sonny first approach
walgreens it's early 2010
and
they
assert to walgreens that they've they
have this technology that can do
hundreds of tests off just a drop of
blood very quickly cheaply et cetera
uh in fact the the last iteration of the
technology the mini lab they haven't
even started working on that they start
working on it in late 2010 so anyways
that's a big lie
and
walgreens should have been able to to
figure that out because they hired a
laboratory consultant by the name of
kevin hunter
to kick the tires and and to to try to
uh check out these claims and and to try
to do some verification
and he even flew out and met with uh
elizabeth holmes and sonny and and other
theronist employees twice
in 2010
and he started asking tough questions
and he started suggesting that they do
things like a 50-patient comparison
study with stanford
and
and elizabeth and sonny didn't like his
questions at all
um and after a couple months of this uh
they they told uh his superiors at
walgreens
we don't want this guy in meetings
anymore
uh they they were they either had these
uh in-person meetings about once a month
or every week these video conference
calls
and uh they wanted him excluded from the
meetings and from the video conference
calls
and uh you know the the unspoken threat
was that uh if
walgreens didn't exclude hunter from the
meetings
uh going forward that you know they
would walk away and and walgreens was
terrified yeah that theranos would walk
away and then go to cvs it's archrival
based in rhode island yeah uh at
walgreens you know people had this
tunnel vision which was we're in a
in a battle to the death with cvs and
everything we do uh is
we see it through that prism
and uh and they were terrified that
theranos would would turn around go to
cvs strike a deal with them and that you
know then they'd be regretting it for
the next 20 years
and so i um i think it's fair to say
that the fear of missing out
otherwise known as fomo uh yeah played
played a unfortunately a big role in
walgreens dropping the ball and not and
excluding kevin hunter he he remained
their consultant for a while longer but
he was kept at arm's length um his role
was really he they made it impossible
for him to do his job
and uh as a result walgreens never
really vetted uh the supposed their nose
technology and then
that was that that was a really
important part of the story because
everyone who came after assumed
walgreens you know this
this blue chip company headquartered in
chicago suburb that's been around for
more than 100 years surely they've done
their homework right surely they've
kicked the tires they wouldn't be
rolling out
a medical technology that people rely on
to make health decisions without having
done their homework and so everyone kind
of assumed that walgreens
had
checked this out and therefore you know
if it was good enough for walgreens it's
good enough for me and they how far down
the road did they get with regard to
actually
testing
customers at walgreens they by the time
i started digging into the company
they had uh commercialized the blood
tests in walgreens stores for more than
a year and a half
and
[Music]
they they were in more than 40 locations
most of them in arizona they had chosen
arizona because um
arizona's
policies are very uh pro-business and
and uh light on regulation that was one
reason and the other was
that the phoenix area has very high
concentration of uninsured patients
and uh theranos
like to advertise its very low
uh prices and it's true that it offered
low prices and it it knew that the
patients who would be sensitive to those
low prices were the patients who
actually had to pay for their labs
uninsured patients because insured
patients and and medicare patients have
their labs covered by insurance
what did they do about the fact that the
technology didn't work i mean
right i mean that's where it gets uh
unbelievable they um
they would try to validate tests on so
the mini lab which was the last version
of the technology
the the edison the second generation of
the technology was limited in that it
could only do one class of blood tests
known as immunoassays and there are
about a half dozen classes of blood
tests and so
the the mini lab was going to be able to
do the other classes of blood tests too
but by the time they rolled out the
finger stick tests in walgreens stores
the mini lab was just a prototype that
didn't work
it was years from from functioning so
they couldn't exactly use that
so they dusted off the the edison
and they tried validating some finger
sticks finger stick tests on the on the
edison uh but according to my source
sources i learned
subsequently when i started digging into
the reporting uh
that the validation uh experiments that
they ran
were very shoddy and they they cut all
sorts of corners they
um
ignore data points i mean it's
very well known in science you don't
ignore any data you don't eliminate any
data points that's uh scientific fraud
and they were engaging in this type of
behavior because they were trying to get
the validation reports for these blood
tests to look
the way they should look in order to put
the tests online and so they did put
about
a half dozen tests online on the edison
that weren't reliable
and because the edison could only do
immunoassays they needed to come up with
a way to pretend that they had
technology to do some of these other
classes of tests so they
hacked a machine called the siemens
advia 1800 which is a big hulking
commercial analyzer that isn't at all
made to test tiny samples of finger
stick blood
but they had the brilliant idea that
they could uh modify this machine
and adapt it to small finger stick
samples and one of the ways they did
that is they diluted the the blood the
finger stick samples to create more
volume because the advia machine um
was uh built to uh
test yeah you know normal sized samples
of blood so to create more volume they
would dilute the blood
and um
there are several problems with that one
is that
there's already a dilution step in the
obvious protocol so this amounted to
double dilution
and
when you're
altering the sample multiple times
you're creating more room for error
the the other thing is that they were
diluting the sample so much that the
analytes whose concentration they were
trying to measure in the blood
the concentration got so low that it
fell beneath the fda approved analytic
measurement range of the machines so it
meant using these machines in the way
that the manufacturer hadn't intended
and the way that the fda certainly
hadn't approved it approved them and it
and it led to
another series of unreliable tests so
that patients now were actually getting
right right uh you know
uh
they did about i think they did about 80
tests using this
hacked method
uh with the siemens machine
well we could go on and on about this
element but i think um
you pretty well established that i will
use the term scam there's a
fair
um of the uh
and i want to go now to where you become
part of the story
if i can put it that way
um
were you first sniffed out something was
different here and how that led to your
right investigation
so um
theranos and elizabeth holmes first came
on my radar when i read a profile of
elizabeth holmes in the new yorker
magazine in late 2014
at that point she'd
become a celebrity it had been about a
year or more
since she had you know risen to fame and
and
she'd graced the the cover of fortune
magazine six months prior and
um
but for me that that's that was the
first time that i discovered that this
company existed and that this young
woman had founded it and then i learned
of the company's valuation and and of
her great wealth and
uh there was a thing there are a couple
things but uh one thing in particular
that struck me as odd as i was reading
that new yorker profile on the subway
home you know from manhattan to brooklyn
where i live
which was this notion that a 19 year old
college dropout
with just two semesters of chemical
engineering uh classes under her belt
had just dropped out and
pioneered you know groundbreaking new
medical science
in silicon this
this has happened before in silicon
valley there have been uh precedents
with mark zuckerberg before him bill
gates you know these guys taught
themselves how to code
and how to program on a computer when
they were young
um legend has it that uh zuckerberg
taught himself how to code on his
father's computer when he was 10 years
old and you know that's believable you
you can do that with a computer manual
and if you spend hours and hours and
hours at the keyboard you can teach
yourself how to code
but you can't really do that in medicine
in medicine you usually have to have
formal training go to medical school
often
do a fellowship get your phd
do post doctoral studies
do years of
research sometimes decade of research
before you start adding value
and as i say in the book
it's no coincidence that most nobel
laureates in medicine earn their nobel
prizes in their 60s
uh it takes a lifetime of of training
and work
to add value in medicine and i knew that
and so
i smelled a rat um
but to be fair
i might not have done anything uh with
that hunch if i hadn't gotten the tip
three or four weeks later
and the tip came from uh
a clinical pathologist uh
who was based in the midwest who
wrote a an obscure blog uh called the
pathology blog
and and he spelled it b-l-a-w-g
and uh
i don't know how many readers he had but
um i would i would speculate that it
wasn't uh much more than 10.
and i i had come across him uh the
previous year uh doing a
a series of uh stories on medicare fraud
and abuse and i had sought his
assistance trying to understand
laboratory billing
and how clinical labs build medicare and
he had patiently explained
the the
arcane art of laboratory billing to me
and i i used that knowledge to expose
this a scam at a network of cancer
centers
but i hadn't spoken to him at that point
in seven or eight months
and he called me um because he had read
the new yorker story too and
knowing a thing or two about blood
testing had been immediately dubious
about the claims in it and had had
quickly posted a short skeptical item on
his blog
and he had been contacted almost
immediately by a little band of theranos
skeptics
one of whom was this guy richard fuse
who had been a childhood neighbor
of elizabeth and her parents
in the 80s when they lived in washington
and was a medical inventor and
entrepreneur
and this is sort of a crazy uh plot
twist but uh when elizabeth dropped out
of stanford and and founded their nose
he and his wife lorraine were still
friends with the holmeses and and
fuse is a very proud um
you know i would say even vain man
and his pride was hurt that the holmes
hadn't sought his advice
even though they knew very well that he
had decades of experience patenting
medical inventions and building
companies and selling companies and so
forth
and so uh and at the same time he
thought elizabeth's vision had merit so
he had gone on the theranos website
checked it out had listened to an
interview she'd given on npr
in 2005 and had figured out that there
was this one part of
her vision that she probably hadn't
patented which was the alert mechanism
to alert doctors when a
blood test result is abnormal and he had
gone ahead and filed a patent and
patented that
and uh you know which
is probably not a very nice thing to do
and uh
she didn't immediately she and her
parents didn't immediately know he had
done that but eventually did because
patent applications are made public in
the
uspto's database 18 months after they're
filed and
then elizabeth had come to develop this
theory that
he had used his son john fuse who had
worked at the same
law firm that berenos had used briefly
to for its patent work and she had
developed this theory that
john fuse had stolen information from
theranos's own provisional patents and
given it to
his father
and and i looked at those allegations uh
very closely and uh the litigation that
arose from them and came to the
conclusion that um what fuse had done
wasn't very nice but he had not stolen
any information from theranos
but she did sue him she sued him in 2011
and
that lawsuit that litigation went on for
three years
and
she hired david boyes
to to litigate that case
and throughout the litigation fuse um
you know who had a background in
medicine and was a trained physician had
become convinced that their nose was a
scam
and so um
he told you know the pathology blogger
of his experience and his suspicions
and it helped that he also had just made
contact with a uh an employee who had
just left theranos
who was the outgoing laboratory director
and so when i heard that you know i was
very conscious of the fact that the
pathology blogger was like
three times removed from any you know
primary information and that fuse
himself whom i talked to as well
was a secondhand source but
the fact that i was being told that
there was a primary source who had just
left the company and was alleging you
know all manner of wrongdoing got me
got my ears
the lab director the lab director yeah
and so from then on it was you know my
mission was to get this lab director on
the phone and make contact with him
and i did um
after a couple weeks and um
he was terrified he was being hounded by
theronis lawyers
he had sent a bunch of emails to himself
to his gmail account and they were
pressuring him to delete them he had
hired a lawyer
she was not a very sh she definitely
wasn't uh
competent to to take on his case and go
up against boy schiller flexner and so
she was intimidated
by um
the heavy duty lawyers on the other side
and and he was under all this stress and
so um he would only speak to me if i
granted him confidentiality and so i did
i figured you know
all i had were rumors and innuendo if i
couldn't get this guy to talk
and i
promised him i would uh treat him as an
anonymous source and i would guard his
his identity which i still do to this
day because he's um identified in the
book under pseudonym he goes by alan
beam which is not his real name
and um
during that first phone call with alan
beam that must have lasted an hour or
more
i learned about you know the fact that
very few of the blood tests were
actually done on theranos technology
that these edison machines were faulty
that most of the tests were done on
commercial instrument that
um you know that they had modified that
um
elizabeth and sonny were a couple and
were hiding it from the board of
directors from employees from the public
you know
henry kissinger had been quoted in the
new yorker piece as saying that
he and his wife had tried to to set
elizabeth up on dates
so it was clear she was lying to her
board about the relationship
um so i i pretty much immediately knew
this was a big story and especially the
part about you know
gambling with patients health and lives
and
at the same time the journal wasn't
going to let me go to print with a story
based on just one source however
good that source was if the source was
anonymous and so
it became a game of corroboration and
over the ensuing months i
set about corroborating what alan beam
was telling me
and um
that's how i came across other former
theranos employees one of whom was tyler
schultz
who was george shultz's grandson
and tyler schultz had worked at
theiranos and had had worked there eight
months and and
come to the uh conviction that it was a
fraud and that it was a scam during his
eight months and at the tail end of his
eight months had tried to
alert his grandfather and and
open his eyes to what was going on and
george hadn't believed him and so he'd
had to
leave theranos and keep all of this
bottled up for a year
and then um when i started poking around
and and calling uh a lot of his
ex-colleagues
he heard that this journal reporter was
was uh poking around and so he looked me
up on on linkedin
and at that point uh alan beam had told
me about tyler and said you know he
might be someone you you can try as well
and i thought the
connection with the grandfather was
interesting
and as you know linkedin has this
feature that enables enables you to see
who's checking out your profile and so i
immediately noticed when tyler schultz
checked out my profile yeah so i sent
him an in-mail through linkedin
didn't hear back for a month
and was was making headway
you know
with the story in other ways and then um
when i had sort of lost hope that he
would get back to me
my phone rings uh one afternoon in the
journal newsroom and it's tyler
uh also terrified very nervous calling
from a burner phone
um because he was he was worried that
theirness would somehow uh you know
trace our communications
and i had to grant him confidentiality
as well otherwise he wouldn't talk to me
um
but once i did he he gradually got
comfortable and i could tell he wanted
to unburden himself and and his story
came pouring forth
um
and that added a pretty uh
uh unbelievable twist to this whole
there are no story
the tyler
george axis
so
last
part of this um
though is
um
you finally decide to publish right
right october 6 2015. yeah and the
company darren you know tyler had good
reason to be paranoid and as did alan
beam because the company did eventually
figure out that they were among my
confidential sources and and
threatened them and um
there's a surreal
incident that's um
recounted in the book about uh the way
tyler was ambushed by theranos lawyers
at his grandfather's own house
um and then had to withstand months of
legal threats um
theronus wanted him to sign documents
basically recant recanting
and also naming my sources and tyler
withstood this pressure and and uh never
caved and so in large part thanks to him
i was able to go depressed with the
story in in uh october of 2015.
so what the
last thing i want to get to audience
questions obviously because they're
better than mine
the uh
but
i'd tell about
how you were treated once
you published the story and
um you know it's like yeah
so the the story was published on
october 15 2015 which i think was a
it was a thursday i think and uh
elizabeth holm was in boston for her
first meeting of the harvard medical
school board of fellows
and so she went on cnbc and she did it
from boston she
spoke to jim cramer and theronus had let
it be known that you know she would
basically rebut the wall street journal
article
at that point i was already working on a
second day story because i had
gotten wind before we went to bed with
the first story that
the fda had inspected the company but i
hadn't gotten confirmation and i was
finally able to get confirmation the day
that the the first story was published
and so i immediately was on deadline
with a second story but
um she came on uh kramer it must have
been like five or six in the afternoon
new york time and so that's that mad
money program yeah
so uh i was standing over the shoulder
of a page one editor who was editing my
story and we both stopped what we were
doing and turned up the volume on the tv
to see what she would have to say and
and um she played the the role of the
aggrieved
uh startup uh silicon valley
entrepreneur who
uh you know is is being attacked by a
reporter in league with
uh you know her competitors namely quest
and lab corp and this entrance
entrenched duopoly that that you know is
pulling my strings and
um
and uh and then
kramer although it's a friendly
interview does ask her uh about some of
the allegations in the article and she
proceeds to dodge and bob and weave
um
and then the next day uh or that night
she flies back to palo alto to address
what is beginning to be a growing crisis
because then my second story comes out
that reveals that the fda has just done
an inspection and
and has uh taken away from theranos the
ability to use its little blood vial
which effectively meant that their nose
could no longer do finger stick testing
and that
evening late afternoon california time
she and sunny
gather
employees in the cafeteria of the
theranos headquarters on page mill road
in palo alto
and uh she gives a defined speech about
how
um you know uh i'm i'm just this biased
reporter who's out to to get her and
this and my reporting is seated by
competitors and by disgruntled employees
and how she's going to
take on the the wall street journal and
the wall street journal is a tabloid she
says
um
and uh
and then sonny goes on and he gives a uh
sort of a defined speech as well and
three months earlier uh if the fda had
approved one of theranos's finger stick
tests the herp this herpes test
and um
uh it had been a big uh moment of
victory for theranos and they had
celebrated in that same cafeteria
and sunny had led the assembled
employees in in a
uh i don't know if i'm allowed to say
that this word but in fu chant yeah and
the fuse had been directed at quest in
lab court
um and at the end of the now we're back
to
two days after my first story and uh at
toward the end of sunny's speech one of
the senior hardware engineers
asks him if he can lead them in another
chant and everyone immediately
understands what he means which chant he
means and and
sonny's of course happy to
indulge him and so they
start chanting
f you carry f you carry
um
and uh
and that's and then um
about a week after that she came to our
technology conference in laguna beach
um
a lot of people uh were wondering
whether she would um
come
and she she she came with her big
security detail and uh
she sat on stage and sat through a third
half an hour interview with our
technology editor
and um there was so much interest in the
story at that point that the journal
live streamed it on its website and i
couldn't go out to california
so i watched it from the newsroom in new
york and
she
told one bald-faced lie after another
uh over the course of that half hour and
and uh i was really i suspected that she
would come out swinging and that she
would deny but um her willingness to
lie in public
in front of an audience and and really
say things that were verifiably false
um i i thought was stunning and um
and yeah so the the early uh parts the
early weeks after the story were
uh
the response was that the wall street
journal is wrong and we're fighting this
and
um you know
right john kerry was a rogue reporter i
suggest that when you read this book
just like they say don't read don't use
your computer you know like a half an
hour or 45 minutes before you want to go
to sleep don't read the latter part of
this book before you want to go to sleep
it
it gets to real john licka ray page
turner
um i'm i want to go to the audience
questions
because they're really good ones um i'm
not going to be able to get to all of
them but i'm going to try to consolidate
some themes here
one of them i think is
suggests that this
a lot of scams start off as scams yep um
and
but that this
did not this started off as a bona fide
a
effort right she didn't i mean i i fully
believe that she did not drop out of
stanford at 19
with a premeditated plan to
defraud investors and to put patients in
harm's way she dropped out as this
idealistic um
young entrepreneur or would-be
entrepreneur
who really did want to follow in the
steps of steve jobs and and she had this
idea this cool idea and she wanted to
make it happen and
she um
had this uh charisma and and um
she
raised a lot of money uh over the years
and uh
made some progress building a device
never really got there
and um
soon started
you know
over promising and lying exaggerating
and the lies got bigger and bigger
and over the course of 12 years it
became a giant lie
and she'll and but she always intended
to catch up
right i think i think in her mind
her attitude was the ends justify the
means it's okay if i cut all these
corners it's okay if i tell all these
lies
because eventually i'll get the
technology right
to deliver on what i've promised and
it will work and then it will be
a great advance for for you know uh
laboratory medicine and it'll be for the
good of society yeah when you see her
interviewed on
uh she's quite passionate about
the long-term social benefit of and i
think a large part of that is genuine
yeah that's my that's the point um and
there many people are curious about so
what has happened to the company now
so um
the elizabeth holmes uh laid off another
100 employees about a month and a half
ago
uh so the head count of the company is
now down to about 20 people it's a shell
of what it was uh
when i started digging into the company
it had 800 employees and
had this beautiful new headquarters
on page mill road in palo alto
they have long since abandoned that
pricey real estate and now that the 20
employees left are in a
manufacturing facility across san
francisco bay and newark
um
uh
the sec has charged her and sonny uh and
the company with fraud
um
she settled uh the fraud charges without
admitting or denying wrongdoing
uh she was fine a half million dollars
uh relinquished most of her shares and
her controlling uh interest in the
company and and agreed to a 10-year
officer director bannon a public company
a lot of people feel like that's a very
light uh punishment given the the
magnitude of the wrongdoing and it's
really a slap on the wrist
and to those people i say
don't forget that there's another
investigation
that's
ongoing a criminal one
spearheaded by the u.s attorney's office
in san francisco
i'm told that's pretty advanced
and uh that that uh criminal charges are
uh very possible and and even likely
um in terms of the company uh the
company probably has another two months
before it runs out of money and and then
will be liquidated i expect it to
cease to exist by august
and um another
um
kind of overarching question that
appears here is
what do what have we learned from this i
mean the vc community what if they
learned the walgreens and
that everybody was affected by this and
is there a other type right i mean i
think that in
recent years we've come to
lionize you know these tech
entrepreneurs
who who create these companies and uh
become fabulously rich and and whose you
know
creations do impact our lives when you
think about facebook and twitter you
know these are products that we use
every day
and uh
we tend to forget that these are young
people um
barely adult you know she was 19 years
old when she dropped out basically a kid
um with the amount of money that's
gushed in the silicon valley in large
part because
the fed has kept interest rates at rock
bottom for 10 years after the the great
recession
so people were no longer able to get
returns for you know from traditional
investments like bonds and so i think
that contributed in a big way
to this enormous uh flow of money into
silicon valley and and people like
elizabeth holmes and these young
founders were able to dictate the terms
and to do whatever they wanted and to in
their noses case uh keep more than 99 of
the voting rights
um yeah the the board couldn't even the
board of directors couldn't even reach a
quorum without her i mean it was it was
that was not a real board of directors
it had no power whatsoever
um and uh it's also given rise to the
situation where where these companies
because they have access to so much
money in the private markets
put off going public uh for a long time
and are able to continue um
operating uh
not in a transparent way at least not as
transparently as they would have to
if the i if they ipo'd and and they
suddenly had to um you know
put out earnings every quarter and put
out uh
annual reports and answer analyst
questions and peer review
and no yeah and then i would say another
another big lesson here is that
um she
modeled herself after the traditional
silicon valley you know the
the silicon valley that started with the
microprocessor industry in the 50s and
60s that became the the personal
computer industry
um that uh became the internet industry
in the late 90s and is now you know
essentially smartphone apps and
companies like uber
um but that's not medicine and and
increasingly there is a convergence
between traditional
tech and
and health um particularly with ai
coming in right and and and so
increasingly there's going to be this
convergence and i think
uh the the theranose story is really a
cautionary tale to
tech founders and and vcs and everyone
involved in this health tech space
that
you always have to remember that when
you're building a device
that is ultimately a medical device used
for medical decisions that your your end
customer is the patient right and that
you should always have the the patient
in mind
um and that vaporware doesn't fly right
or the blue screen of death yeah
the
last question because one of the
lingering
from here again one of the lingering
thoughts that she had which was really
a
paradigm shift in medicine was
the retailization i'll call it of blood
testing so that we could go to walgreens
and find out what our cholesterol level
is or whatever we're interested in is is
that going to occur do you think i mean
that that was not necessarily a bad idea
um one of the ironies of uh the theron's
debacle is that safeway you know
invested 350 million dollars in
remodeling uh the
the pharmacy sections of its uh
supermarkets
and um uh for years now uh these areas
have been these little clinics have been
empty but um in the past couple years uh
sonora quest
in arizona has reached a partnership
with safeway and and is offering uh
uh blood tests to to retail consumers
um hopefully it's an request isn't you
know their results are more reliable
yeah than theranos um
uh one thing to
to bear in mind about about their nose
is that it like to and elizabeth liked
to advertise how low that the prices
were
but
that was a fiction too it was not a
fiction in the sense that their nose
wasn't offering those prices it was
but uh what was a fiction was that uh
the company that that was a business
model that could work and that the
company could actually make money
that way um
there really was no secret way that
theiranos was going to make those low
prices uh profitable it had the same
costs as other labs
uh and and in lab testing you know there
there are enormous cost costs of
equipment cost of personnel cost of
shipping right the blood samples is an
enormous cost and regulatory costs and
regulatory costs and and uh theranose
had made none of those costs really go
away so
that was a mirage the low prices
were not
something that was sustainable
well
we are out of time but i
there's two ways for you to follow up on
this number one is get this book and
read it and the second is wait for the
movie to come out
tell us who is
thank you very much yep
yeah
thanks thank you yeah that's great thank
you
[Music]
here's a look at some